bien tout d'abord nous tenons à apporter
notre soutien à toute la famille les
collègues et les élèves de ce professeur
qui a été victime d'un acte terrible
ensuite dès demain il ya des
rassemblements dans toute l'académie de
dijon dans tous les départements à 15
heures à l'image de ce qui se passe à
paris
ensuite ce qu'est ce qu'on attend du
gouvernement tout simplement que des
enseignants qui doivent enseigner les
valeurs de la république se sentent
protégés et soutenu par l'institution
mais dans la durée
aussi puisque voilà hier il ya eu
l'émotion il ya eu des paroles très
fortes du président de la république
par contre on attendait des actes
concrets maintenant et on sera vigilant
pour la suite